I want to play this this video before we
get to the next segment because I think
it's just great uh this is body cam
footage of a traffic stop where a woman
was driving on the wrong side of the
road as women do sometimes and uh she
gets pulled over officer smells alcohol
on her breath what makes this inter this
interaction so incredible is that she
runs through a checklist of her victim
points one after another and the whole
thing is like some kind of skit in fact
I hope it's not a SK I don't think it is
a skit I mean as far as I know this is
real this is an actual thing uh yes it
is real um so it's not a skit but but
you would think I mean you would think
that it was a skit you would think it
would be something that like we would
have put together to be funny um when
you see how this interaction unfolds
let's watch it what's going on nothing
why are you driving in the wrong way of
traffic no I just got changed around I
just moved here like 2 months ago and I
just got changed around okay do you
understand what's going on though you're
going into oncoming traffic I know and I
just decided that it was better just to
turn around really quick okay but I'm
sorry I just have like really bad social
anxiety and stuff I get I don't want to
step out whenever you're asking
for stuff okay well we're past that just
go ahead step out okay pause it there so
that was the keep track of the
victim well this thing is three and a
half minutes long so we're watch whole
thing I don't know if we're going to get
to every victim point but she's already
she's pulled out one of them um she has
social anxiety now I don't know what
social anxiety has to do with driving on
the wrong side of the road um in fact
generally if you have social anxiety
that's going to make your social anxiety
that's not a good strategy for
alleviating social anxiety um driving on
the wrong side of the road if anything
is going to make it worse people are
staring at you now uh and now the whole
world is watching you and the body Camp
footage so that's it's not it's I don't
know what it has to do with
anything I I but of course she's saying
it because she's looking for sympathy so
this this was the first first attempt I
have social anxiety and I guess she was
expecting that the cop would say oh you
have you have anxiety oh
well continue on your way on the wrong
side of the road if you want continue I
I had no idea I didn't know you had
anxiety I wouldn't want to make you more
anxious so go ahead go ahead and get in
a head- on collision kill yourself and
somebody else if it would make you less
anxious ma'am uh well not ma'am we'll
get to that let's keep watching this
person right back here please Miss Perry
am I well I'm non-binary so okay what do
you go buy Kai how can I refer to you
tonight okay okay hey I'm smelling
alcohol I know how much have you
consumed tonight like probably three
drink I need to run you through some
test right now stand facing me please
but I just want you know that I also
have very bad social anxiety you and me
both okay okay any recent head trauma
traumatic brain injuries anything I need
to know about uh mental yes
yeah we can tell focus on my finger
please all right I think we missed I
think I talked over we so she said IND
so we had uh anxiety and then she says
I'm an IND as she's getting out of the
car I think we missed that it's
unfortunate this a good moment uh as
she's getting out of the car she says
I'm an indigenous person for okay uh and
then she throws out non-binary and then
she goes back to the anxiety well again
uh and then and then we go to mental um
and then she so she has a what's now I'm
blanking on what's the word they use now
for mental health
did anyway I forget what it is uh but
she has she has she is a mental health
oh neurode Divergent that's the that's
where she doesn't use that unfortunately
so maybe that's maybe that maybe that
would have been the ticket I mean she
threw out uh social anxiety indigenous
non-binary she said she has mental
health issues but maybe if she had just
said neurod Divergent that would have
been the fourth thing and then that and
that would have been the get out of jail
free card the cop would have said okay
well then if you got all four of those
okay all four then uh please be on your
way um and eventually she gets arrested
because she's obviously drunk uh which
so it's good you know it's a happy
ending at the end um but the thing that
makes this seem like a skit is it's just
this and this is what these people have
become they really have become a self-
parody and this is someone who she
obviously has gone through her whole
life like this that she just assumes
that no matter what happens no matter
what she does um she can always get off
the hook by just throwing out the victim
credentials and mo more than likely we
can assume this is probably the first
time in her life ever that that tactic
has not worked everybody knows that I
love my Helix mattress but did you know
that they they just launched their
newest most high-end collection Helix
Elite Helix has harnessed years of
extensive mat expertise to bring their
customers a truly elevated sleep
experience the Helix Elite collection
includ includ six different mattress
models each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years and I love it
it's the best mattress I ever had if
you're nervous about buying a mattress
online you don't have to be Helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the imperfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for somebody else go to
helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free plus Helix has a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will their financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20% off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for my listeners go to Helix sleep.com
wolf this is their best offer yet it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now I mean you do people a great
favor when you hold them accountable
when when you uh when you don't put up
with that kind of I mean it and Kids
when you're raising your kids why you
got to have consequences for your
children this is someone probably as a
child never had any
consequences it's a it's a great Act of
love for them because when someone lives
into adulthood and never really
experiences a natural consequence for
their actions never has any real
encounter with accountability they're
always able to get get out of trouble um
by making victims of themselves it yeah
it makes them a drain on society it
makes them a danger to society
ultimately but it all it has it
basically drives them crazy it drives
them
insane a a person can't live like that
you can't live a life totally devoid of
consequence and still remain a mentally
healthy and stable
person and so that's how you end up with
that hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there